f with the rer wide Tory KR the former Bruin
takes a shot kicked out by bosski and here comes
benett and BAGI trying to clear it out now they do
kachuck moves in with mour the pass the shot Rises
high as mour hammered that towards the net Here
Comes kyou against Mika final 30 seconds as things
open up a little bit chance in the slot big save
by bosski on B navic he said it's going to be take
a little time he already said that so Bennett
is in Bennett with a Chance off the post oh
what a rush by Bennett Blues don't take men many
penalties tied for the fewest times short-handed
in the lead big chance here may not get too
many k Chuck in front just couldn't get to that
rebound onour rushes ahead for Bennett Bennett
puts it in front the chance and the save is made
by hon Rodriguez twice couple of posts only
allowed one shot on goal so far Kyu over to
H naich puts it out in front kyou there's the
second shot and Sergey bosski is there klat
he'll flip this Puck out Panthers just continue
to have it on lock down defensively against the
blues cats have been great def ly most of this
season here's a chance though that one goes
wide Bennett finished the check on fa kachuck
jumps up to play it Matthew kachuck centers
for hiy tip wide I think that hit Bennett
right out in front that puck slowed down on
himo gets
in they understand the importance in the role
model that they the role models that they play and
they're happy to do it cousins in behind the net
here's stenland looking shooting stopped and the
cover for haggy as the Panthers kept it in with
a shot sa rebound is right there in front of the
net but the blues are on it cousins absorbs the
hit makes the play finds loara couldn't pop it
out in front blle up the boards not out Panthers
good work to hold it in by cousins there's a love
saying couple of posts from bened and Chuck
early in the game Chucks got it floats it ahead
for Bennett down the boards Bennett speeding
in Bennett's got it to the net saved by hoper
for hay trying to find the rebound but couldn't
the blues are going to try and stand up at their
own Blue Line the Panthers will have success
just little short little passes chip it in
that open space behind the defense put out in
front Shi it's off the crossbar from stenland
pressure scandel a good play by Lockwood forced
the turnover scandel again turns it over again
to lomber bomberg over the line still has it
he fires glove save very active game tonight
for Sam Bennett Panthers get it deep in the zone
good play by Bennett behind the net to fight off
the Checker now it's Brandon Montour Bennett again
fires saved Puck is loose at the net for higgy and
he just stops and then he puts it in front again
and it went off that side of the post what does
that line have to do to get a goal they are all
over the net now a chance the other way deflect
it on go B brovsky the save not really a shot it
pinballed on that that's the Blue's best chance
they had but yeah Bennett ver hagy now the blues
coming it's a three-on-one Kyu Bo navic and he
flubbed it and put it wide Kyu shoots and he
scores this time and the blues have the game
first goal for haggy and then finally the Panthers
they just couldn't get organized defensively back
there's just too many men they at the passing play
they missed the the back of the net Thomas puts it
to the side get it through to two defenseman
into an empty net so St Louis breaks out on
top Here Comes kyou again bnic for Kyu in front
the pass back and they score again oh a couple
of quick ones Blue Line watch Rodriguez here
he's got control and then it just can't play
that Puck and that leads to the odd man
rush and beautiful passing play tic tac
toe and B nitz gets the wide open goal as Sergey
bosi came and committed himself to kyou here's
the quick call and the official call be made from
Morgan mcfield after video review is determined
that the play was offside therefore we have
no goal reset the clock to 14 sends it around
the race to the boards Samy blade for St Louis
knocked away lomberg in front Lawrence with a
Chance over for the save and the rebound wide
from Lockwood William Lockwood looking for his
first NHL goal lomberg with a good effort gets
it to benett now the Panthers now buzzing lomberg
shot blocked in front chuck all the way through
to forsling Knocked away and look out Panthers
in the midst of a change Montour came on here's
Thomas in the slot over to kyou over to bnic on
the backand and he scores and now it's two nothing
St Louis this one will count for bnic oh for the
love of Santa's Little Helpers the Panthers had
a bad change forsling turns the puck over and
here comes the St Louis Blues a Nifty passing ktic
tac toe right out in front B nich on the backand
after again Sergey bosi had committed himself
and then you see the short side that's open two
in the first St here in the second Thomas goes
across and the Panthers are all over that eblad
and Thomas behind the play were going at it as the
catch shoot in and they score it hit the glass and
it bounced in now the blues are objecting they're
saying this is no goal that it caught something
in the panther bench first but it did deflect in
and this is going to be interesting got to see
where that puck hit on its way in Randy so here's
the breakout Moyer ind's got the puck fires it it
just hit the glass it hit the round part of the
glass if you stop it right here there's a right
at the panther bench I know it's kind of fuzzy
but there's was a round partition here to protect
the players and it just took a really funny HP
and he gets tied up and checked and the puck is
cleared KW gets into the panther Zone it's B
navic again on the backand knocked away Thomas
is stopped by bosski there's that big save from
Sergey bosski the Panthers needed now late in
the second things are opening up again oh sad
with a steel sad backhand off the outside of
the net played up to scandel the wrist shot
up through and they score traffic in front
scandel shot gets through it's a two-goal game
again incredible incredible with the Panthers
scandel will keep an eye on it change directions
right there and in behind Sergey boski as Kula
cof and Oliver Ekman Larson looked like they
had good positioning on their men but there's a
deflection Nick lety sends it ahead Montour
keeps in for Bennett Bennett jammed up in the
corner the battle is on up the boards mour barov
picks it up he turns he shoots blocked in front
by Paro big Colton Paro stationed in front
of that net and sent towards the empty net
and in quickly B naav his second goal of the
night and it's 4-1 Blues he would have had a
hat-trick if they they didn't call the other
one back Panthers desperate to get the puck to
the front of the net just couldn't get a hold
of it there was a swing in a Miss by Montour
and then onto the stick it was forward up
to bich and it ends in a 4-1 win for the
blues here in South Florida yeah another
game where the Panthers just out chance
the opposition but got down and just could
not climb back once they were down 3 to one